Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Saturday 5th October 1974 was a big night for Paul Cray and Carol Burns. By coincidence, their birthdays fell on the same day, and Paul, who was due to turn 22, thought it would be nice to have a little party. Only a few weeks earlier, Carol, three years his junior, had been accepted into the Women's Royal Army Corps, so they had something special to celebrate.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入会员。网址是 therestishistory.com。1974年10月5日星期六，对保罗·克雷（Paul Cray）和卡罗尔·伯恩斯（Carol Burns）来说是一个重要的夜晚。巧合的是，他们的生日在同一天，即将满22岁的保罗觉得举办一个小派对会很不错。就在几周前，比他小三岁的卡罗尔刚被女子皇家陆军军团（Women's Royal Army Corps）录取，所以他们有特别的理由庆祝。
She chose the venue, a pub not far from her barracks, recommended by some of her new friends who used to meet their boyfriends there on Saturday nights. Meanwhile, Paul had a surprise up his sleeve. Unbeknown to Carol, he had invited her parents down from Boreham Wood for the evening, and when she left headquarters, all three of them were waiting outside to greet her. They walked on to the pub, the Horse and Groom in Guildford, which was already filling up. The atmosphere was noisy, happy. Many of the drinkers were soldiers and their girlfriends, enjoying a night out. The Burns family found a table in an alcove by the jukebox. Carol disappeared to the toilet for a minute or two.
她选择了地点，那是离她军营不远的一家酒吧，是她的一些新朋友推荐的，她们过去常在周六晚上在那里见男朋友。与此同时，保罗还准备了一个惊喜。卡罗尔不知道，他邀请了她的父母从博勒姆伍德（Boreham Wood）赶来参加晚会。当她离开总部时，他们三个人都在外面等着迎接她。他们步行前往吉尔福德（Guildford）的“马与新郎”（Horse and Groom）酒吧，那里已经挤满了人。气氛嘈杂而欢乐。许多酒客都是士兵和他们的女朋友，正在享受夜晚的时光。伯恩斯一家在点唱机旁的一个凹室里找到了座位。卡罗尔消失了一两分钟去上厕所。
When she came back, Paul had moved up and taken her seat, so she slipped in beside him. It was almost nine o'clock. Then, quite suddenly, there was a gigantic bang and everything went black. The next thing Carol knew, she was lying on the ground, her ears full of buzzing, her mouth full of smoke and dust. Someone was lying on the floor beside me, she said later. It was Paul. So Dominic, that is from your history of Britain in 1974 to 1979, Seasons in the Sun. And it describes what has been commemorated as the Guildford Pub bombing.
当她回来时，保罗已经挪动位置坐了她的位子，所以她滑到他身边坐下。当时快九点了。然后，突然之间，一声巨响，一切都陷入了黑暗。卡罗尔醒来时，发现自己躺在地上，耳朵里嗡嗡作响，嘴里满是烟尘。她后来回忆说，有人躺在我旁边的地板上。那是保罗。那么，多米尼克，这段内容出自你关于1974年至1979年英国历史的著作《太阳下的季节》（Seasons in the Sun）。它描述了后来被称为“吉尔福德酒吧爆炸案”的纪念事件。
So Paul is dead? Yes. Paul was killed straight away. He's one of five people killed that evening, 5th of October, 1974. There was a bomb in the alcove that you mentioned by the jukebox that had been planted by the Provisional IRA. It's a reminder of how chance matters in history because when Carol went to the toilet, they moved places. If she was still sitting where she had been, she would have been killed, not Paul. Her parents were very badly injured. Her father, I think, was in a coma for five weeks.
所以保罗死了？是的。保罗当场遇难。他是1974年10月5日那天晚上遇难的五人之一。你提到的点唱机旁边的凹室里有一枚炸弹，是临时派（Provisional IRA）安放的。这提醒了我们偶然性在历史中有多重要，因为当卡罗尔去上厕所时，他们换了位置。如果她还坐在原来的地方，死的就是她，而不是保罗了。她的父母受了重伤。我想她的父亲昏迷了五周。
Four other people were killed, 68 people injured. Two of the people who died were teenagers, teenage girls who'd also joined the Women's Royal Army Corps, and two teenage boys, Scots Guards, Sir William Forsyth and James Hunter, who were friends from the same street in Renfrewshire, who had only joined up a month beforehand. And the Guildford pub bombing sent an absolute shockwave through Britain. There have been many bombings, of course, in Northern Ireland in the last couple of years, but this was seen as something, a bomb in a pub in Britain, in the home counties, was seen as unbelievably shocking. And of course, what made it more shocking, Tom, was that afterwards, the police charged four innocent people
另有四人死亡，68人受伤。死者中有两名十几岁的女孩，她们也加入了女子皇家陆军军团；还有两名十几岁的男孩，是苏格兰卫队的威廉·福赛斯爵士（Sir William Forsyth）和詹姆斯·亨特（James Hunter），他们是来自伦弗鲁郡（Renfrewshire）同一条街的朋友，才入伍一个月。吉尔福德酒吧爆炸案在英国引起了巨大的震动。当然，过去几年北爱尔兰发生过许多爆炸案，但这被视为一件极其令人震惊的事——在英国本土、在伦敦周边郡县的酒吧里发生爆炸。当然，汤姆，更令人震惊的是，事后警方指控了四名无辜者，
who went to prison for 15 years. Yeah, because that's what it's chiefly remembered for now, isn't it? Yes. And almost certainly the culprits were a group called the Balcombe Street Gang, who were a provisional IRA unit who were kind of on the loose in England in 1974 and 1975, and who actually said at their trial in 1977,
他们坐了15年的牢。是的，因为这正是现在人们主要记住它的原因，不是吗？是的。而且几乎可以肯定，罪魁祸首是一个叫“巴尔科姆街帮”（Balcombe Street Gang）的组织，他们是临时派爱尔兰共和军的一个小组，1974年和1975年在英国流窜作案，他们实际上在1977年的审判中承认，
there were innocent people in prison for the Guildford pub bombing, but the police and someone didn't listen. So yeah, it's a pretty shocking story. And we're at the final episode of this 1974 marathon, and this is five days before the general election campaign, the second general election in 1974, which is where we ended, didn't we, last time? Harold Wilson has decided on the showdown with Ted Heath to try and give himself the mandate, because he's been leading a minority government. And this sort of darkness overshadows the election. And you described in the previous episode how Wilson is seen by many people on the right as so illegitimate as actually to be potentially a Soviet mole. People on the left are talking with some justification of the possibility of a right-wing coup.
吉尔福德酒吧爆炸案中有无辜者入狱，但警方和某些人并没有听。所以，这是一个相当令人震惊的故事。我们现在是1974年马拉松系列的最后一集，距离大选竞选还有五天，这是1974年的第二次大选，也就是我们上次结束的地方，对吧？哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）决定与泰德·希思（Ted Heath）进行决战，试图为自己争取授权，因为他一直领导着一个少数派政府。这种黑暗笼罩着选举。你在上一集中描述了威尔逊在右翼许多人眼中是多么不合法，甚至可能是一个苏联间谍。左翼人士则有理有据地谈论着右翼政变的可能性。
Yes. So there is a sense of extreme polarisation in the country. And then to have this act of brutal violence, as you say, in the home counties, in Surrey, one of the richest and most prosperous areas in Britain. I assume then that it must have radically enhanced the sense that many people have that this is a state of crisis like none that Britain has faced since the war? I think what it doesn't do is to create a sort of what you might call a histrionic or extreme reaction. Actually, what it adds to is a sense, I think, of weariness, of depression. Because don't forget, the conflict in Northern
是的。所以全国范围内有一种极端的两极分化感。然后发生了这种残酷的暴力行为，正如你所说，在伦敦周边郡县，在萨里郡（Surrey），这是英国最富裕、最繁荣的地区之一。我假设这一定从根本上加剧了许多人的感觉，即这是一个自战争以来英国从未面临过的危机状态？我认为它并没有制造出一种所谓的夸张或极端的反应。实际上，我认为它增加了一种疲惫感和压抑感。因为别忘了，北爱尔兰的冲突
Ireland has been going on since the late 1960s. So we're into kind of year five a bit now. And most people don't understand it. Most people in Great Britain don't understand it. They don't really care, to be brutally honest. But they are horrified by it and by the fact that it is, as they see it, seeping into the life of... So the Times actually says that, doesn't it? It says that no election since the war had been held in such a mood of public uncertainty
从20世纪60年代末就开始了。所以我们现在进入了第五个年头。大多数人并不理解它。英国的大多数人并不理解它。说实话，他们并不真正关心。但他们对此感到恐惧，因为正如他们所见，它正在渗透到……所以《泰晤士报》实际上是这样说的，不是吗？它说，自战争以来，没有任何一次选举是在这样一种公众不确定性
and depression. So depression rather than anger. Yes. I mean, there is anger, as we will see later on. There are people who are calling for the death penalty for terrorists because the death penalty had been done away with just a few years earlier. But I think it adds to a sense of kind of world weariness, of shabbiness, of ineffectual government, and a sense of helplessness, actually, I guess is the word, Tom, that Britain is now, having been for so long the great actor on the world stage, that for the first time, I think, in the mid-1970s, people realised that Britain is actually on the receiving end of change and of major geopolitical developments.
和压抑的情绪中举行的。所以是压抑而不是愤怒。是的。我的意思是，确实有愤怒，我们稍后会看到。有些人呼吁对恐怖分子判处死刑，因为死刑在几年前才被废除。但我认为这增加了一种世界性的疲惫感、破败感、政府的无能，以及一种无助感，汤姆，我想这才是那个词，英国长期以来一直是世界舞台上的主角，但在20世纪70年代中期，人们第一次意识到英国实际上正处于变革和重大地缘政治发展的接收端。
And there's a sense of impotence, I think, impotence of the government to do anything about Northern Ireland, but impotence to deal with inflation or the pace of globalisation and de-industrialisation and all of these kinds of things. And is there a sense also of, I might almost say boredom, tedium, a sense that this is just an endless cycle of two rather shop-soiled leaders in the form of Wilson and Heath? Neither of them are inspirational. Neither of them really seem to promise a kind of radical change. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. So, Wilson, who we talked about a lot last time, the sort of chaotics, I mean, some people might think we were being a bit harsh on Wilson, that sort of chaotic six-month period after he became
而且我认为有一种无能感，政府在北爱尔兰问题上无能为力，在应对通货膨胀、全球化步伐和去工业化等问题上也无能为力。是否还有一种，我几乎可以说厌倦、乏味的感觉，觉得这只是威尔逊和希思这两个相当陈旧的领导人之间无休止的循环？他们两人都无法鼓舞人心。他们两人似乎都没有承诺某种激进的变革。是的，我认为这绝对正确。所以，威尔逊，我们上次谈了很多，那种混乱的六个月时期，在他成为
Prime Minister. But actually, the chaos really continues into the election campaign. So, the very first meeting of his election team tom has to be moved from room to room because marcia williams who played such a leading role in the last episode she's very keen that her nemesis in his high command to her joe haynes his press secretary and bernard donahue is his policy chief i mean to be fair they have been plotting to murder her they have right but But they've been discussing plotting to murder her. They haven't actually been plotting. I think that's semantic.
首相之后。但实际上，混乱确实延续到了竞选活动中。所以，汤姆，他的竞选团队的第一次会议不得不从一个房间换到另一个房间，因为在上一集中扮演了重要角色的玛西娅·威廉姆斯（Marcia Williams），她非常希望她在高层指挥部的克星——她的新闻秘书乔·海恩斯（Joe Haynes）和政策主管伯纳德·多诺霍（Bernard Donoghue）——公平地说，他们一直在密谋除掉她，他们确实有，对吧？但他们一直在讨论密谋除掉她。他们并没有真正实施。我认为那是语义问题。
She doesn't want them to come to the meetings. She keeps changing the room behind their back. Right. So that sort of behavior. Also, Wilson gets tanked up on brandy before his first TV broadcast. So there's that sort of sense of general seediness and shabbiness in one answer. So Wilson's having all kinds of trouble with Marcia. What about, so there's Tony Benn, who's been kicking up all kinds of, basically is foisting
她不想让他们参加会议。她背着他们不断更换房间。对。就是那种行为。此外，威尔逊在第一次电视广播前喝了白兰地。所以，总的来说，有一种普遍的肮脏和破败感。所以威尔逊在玛西娅身上遇到了各种麻烦。那么，托尼·本（Tony Benn）呢，他一直在制造各种麻烦，基本上是强加
policies on Wilson that he doesn't really want. That's right. Wilson doesn't really want to go into that election with any policies at all, Tom, because Wilson's great thing. You said about people being bored. Wilson wants people to be bored because his promise is, I will give you a quiet life. No more conflict with the unions. We've got our lovely social contract, which fans of Russo will remember from the last
给威尔逊一些他并不真正想要的政策。没错。威尔逊并不真的想带着任何政策进入那场选举，汤姆，因为威尔逊最看重的是。你刚才说人们感到厌倦。威尔逊希望人们感到厌倦，因为他的承诺是：我会给你们平静的生活。不再与工会发生冲突。我们有可爱的社会契约，Russo的粉丝们会记得上一集的内容，我们基本上会给工会他们想要的工资协议。然后我们会给他们很多额外的福利，比如健康和安全方面的东西。作为回报，他们会缓和未来的工资要求。另一方面，托尼·本是国有化、国家企业委员会、国家规划的伟大信徒，
episode, where we will basically give the unions the pay deals they want. And we will then give them lots of extra goodies like health and safety stuff and all these things. And in return, they will moderate their future pay demands. Tony Benn, on the other hand, is the great apostle of nationalization, of a national enterprise board, of state planning
以及所有这些东西。他是那个伟大的“妖怪”。威尔逊基本上试图在整个竞选期间把他关在盒子里。而且一直有各种故事传到工党高层，
and all this stuff. And he's the great bogeyman. And Wilson basically tries to keep him in a box throughout the election campaign. And there are all these stories that keep coming into Labour High Command
说报纸正在准备关于托尼·本的惊人揭露，说他是瘾君子。哦，真的吗？因为，我的意思是，托尼·本是最节制的人，不是吗？他是。他滴酒不沾。
that the newspapers are preparing these amazing revelations about Tony Benn, that he's a drug addict. Oh, really? Because, I mean, Tony Benn is the most abstemious of men, isn't he? He is. He's a teetotaler.
他喜欢喝茶。他非常喜欢喝茶。但仅此而已。而且，正如我们在《历史的余味》第二次历史版“恋爱岛”中发现的那样，他非常爱他的妻子卡罗琳。这是伟大的政治爱情故事之一。但报纸显然也准备了这个故事，说他正在一个叫比肯霍尔公馆（Bickenhall Mansions）的地方参加狂欢派对，那是在马里波恩（Marleybone）的一个爱德华时代公寓大楼。
He loves his tea. He loves his teetot. But nothing more than that. And he also, as we discovered when he appeared in The Restless History's second historical Love Island, he very much loves his wife, Caroline. It's one of the great political love stories. But the newspapers also had apparently prepared this story that he was taking part in orgies at a place called Bickenhall Mansions, which is in Marleybone, an Edwardian mansion block.
《星期日镜报》编辑把这个故事传给了哈罗德·威尔逊，威尔逊把本叫了进来，他一边抽着烟斗一边对他说，这是真的吗？你一直在参加这些狂欢派对吗？本对此感到非常冒犯，因为显然他没有。嗯，他当然会感到冒犯。这是小报真正开始针对托尼·本的时候吗？因为从这一点开始，他将成为那个伟大的仇恨对象，不是吗？他是小报所说的“疯狂左派”的旗手。
Sunday Mirror editor passed the story to Harold Wilson and Wilson called Ben in and he said, sort of smoked his pipe at him and said, is it true? Have you been taking part in orgies in these? And Ben was very offended by this because obviously he hadn't. Well, he would be, of course. And is this the point where the tabloids really start going after Tony Benn? Because from this point on, he will be the great hate object, won't he? He's the kind of the standard bearer of what the tabloids call the loony left.
是的。所以他们在大约10年后才真正创造出“疯狂左派”这个词，但在这一点上，他们绝对称他为政委、布尔什维克，诸如此类。实际上，威尔逊在接下来的几周竞选活动中，竭尽全力把本藏在一张巨大的毯子下。所以这一切都非常、非常鼓舞人心。与此同时，爱德华·希思（Edward Heath）呢？嗯，泰德·希思的粉丝们可能不会喜欢上一集，因为他缺席了。他去生闷气了。他被击败了。我认为公平地说，泰德·希思是进入1974年10月竞选时最彻底的失败者，
Yes. So they don't really coin the loony left phrase for another 10 years, but absolutely at this point, they're calling him a commissar, a Bolshevik, all this kind of thing. And actually, Wilson goes out of his way to sort of basically hide Ben under a massive blanket for the next few weeks during the election campaign. So that's all very, very inspiring. And meanwhile, what about Edward Heath? Well, so Ted Heath, fans of Ted Heath will have not enjoyed the previous episode because he was absent. He was off sulking. He's been defeated. I think it's fair to say Ted Heath is the most busted of busted flushes going into the
因为他从没想过自己会输，汤姆，那第一次选举。现在我知道这对你来说是一个悲伤的时刻，因为你是索尔兹伯里人。泰德·希思当然以住在索尔兹伯里而闻名，一个伟大的威尔特郡人。我不知道你是否喜欢游艇和弹钢琴之类的东西。我不喜欢游艇，不。但他的游艇撞毁了，不是吗？在选举前几个月。是的，他极其倒霉。希思患有未确诊的甲状腺疾病。他的游艇“晨云号”（Morning Cloud）在怀特岛沉没，船上两人死亡。其中一人是他的教子。所以这是一件非常糟糕的事情。
October 1974 campaign because he never thought he was going to lose, Tom, that first election. And now I know this is a sad moment for you because you're a man of Salisbury. Ted Heath, of course, famously went to live in Salisbury, a great Wiltshire man. I don't know if you like yachting and piano playing and stuff. I don't really like yachting, no. But his yacht crashes, doesn't it? A couple of months before the election. Yeah, he's unbelievably unlucky. He's got an undiagnosed thyroid complaint, Heath. His yacht, Morning Cloud, sank at the Isle of Wight and two people died on it. One of whom was his godson. So that's a very bad business.
是的，那很悲伤。他整个夏天都像帽贝一样紧紧抓住保守党领导权不放。他确实是这样，不是吗？他去拜访毛主席，毛主席送了他两只熊猫。熊猫，是的。
Yeah, that is sad. And he has clung on to the Tory leadership like a limpet all through the summer. He does, doesn't he? He goes to visit Chairman Mao who gives him a couple of pandas. Pandas, yeah.
这没有提升他的形象吗？没有。他的一个朋友说，毛是他几个月来见到的第一个真正高兴见到他的人，这对你的朋友来说是一句刻薄的话。
Has that not boosted his profile? No. One of his friends said Mao was the first person he'd seen in months who was actually pleased to see him, which is a harsh thing for one of your friends
那确实很刻薄。现在，泰德·希思和保守党在1974年10月所做的事情，汤姆，你会喜欢的，因为你非常像一个……我的意思是，不是要对你刻薄，你是一个中间派老爸，不是吗？最终。我想是吧。泰德·希思运行了终极的、绝对的中间派老爸，罗里·斯图尔特（Rory Stewart），休息一下，他的政治竞选。
to say about you. That is harsh. Now, the thing that Ted Heath and the Tories do in October 1974 see him, which is a harsh thing for one of your friends to say about you. Yeah, that is harsh. Now, the thing that Ted Heath and the Tories do in October 1974, Tom, which you will enjoy because you're very much a kind of, I mean, without being mean to you, you're a centrist dad, aren't you? Ultimately. I guess. And Ted Heath runs the ultimate, the absolutely ultimate centrist dad, Rory Stewart, rest
好吧，我迫不及待想看看它是否能让他掌权。是的。你可以从中判断它会有多有效。这个中间派老爸宣言的表现形式是什么？首先，他的助手对他说，你在1974年2月太尖刻了。脱掉你的西装。记住罗里·斯图尔特脱掉了他的领带。
his politics campaign. Well, I can't wait to see if it sweeps him to power. Yes. And you can gauge from that how effective it's going to be. What's the manifestation of this centrist dad manifesto? First of all, his aides say to him, you were too abrasive in February 1974. Take off your suit. Remember that Rory Stewart took off his tie.
他确实脱了。所以服装元素在这里很重要。脱掉你的西装，穿着衬衫袖子或者一件可爱的毛衣在全国各地走动。做一个和蔼可亲、友好、风趣的人。现在，泰德·希思不是一个风趣的人。但他们也说，听着，我们不能仅仅作为我们自己获胜。我们必须说我们代表，
He did, yeah. So the sartorial element is important here. Take off your suit and go around the country in your shirt sleeves or indeed in a cuddly jumper. And being a vuncular, friendly, jovial fellow. Now, Ted Heath is not a jovial man. But also they say, listen, we're not going to win as just ourselves. We have to say that we stand for,
这就是你的政治观点发挥作用的地方，一个民族团结联合政府，一个明智的政府。让我们把人们聚在桌子旁。把党派争吵放在一边。好的。所以他有他所有的部长。我能问你关于一位特定的部长以及她如何——是谁？她如何——哦，对。我能问你关于一位特定的部长以及她如何对这个做出反应吗？这就是教育大臣，撒切尔夫人（Mrs. Thatcher）。
and this is where your politics comes in, a national unity coalition government, a sensible government. Let's get people together around the table. Put aside the partisan bickering. Okay. So he's got all his ministers. Can I ask you about one particular minister and how- Who's it going to be? How she- Oh, right. Can I ask you about one particular minister and how she reacts to this? And this is the Education Secretary, Mrs. Thatcher.
是的。她并不是希思政府中的一颗明星，我不会这么说。他们很相似，不是吗？所以他们都来自某种小资产阶级背景，可以这么说。是的，但略有不同。她的背景稍微体面一点。她的父亲是市议员，经营一家商店。泰德·希思的父亲基本上是个建筑工人。
Yes. So she had not been a great star of Heath's government, I wouldn't have said. They're quite similar, aren't they? So they're both from kind of petty bourgeois backgrounds, one might say. Yeah, but slightly different. Hers is a little bit more respectable. Her father was an alderman and ran a shop. Ted Heath's father was basically a builder.
我认为结果就是，她比泰德·希思更热衷于宣扬自己的背景。所以泰德·希思对自己的背景感到尴尬，并把自己重新包装成贵族。撒切尔夫人是一个尖锐、有抱负的中下层阶级战士，而希思并不是。但在这一点上，我的意思是，她是否热情地支持希思的宣言和竞选计划？她是全力以赴还是置身事外？不，她喜欢它。嗯，看起来很喜欢。
And I think as a result, she is much keener to trumpet her background than Ted Heath is. So Ted Heath's been embarrassed about his background and rebrands himself as a patrician. Mrs. Thatcher is a sort of sharp-elbowed, aspirational, lower-middle-class warrior in a way that Heath isn't really. But at this point, I mean, is she enthusiastically supporting Heath's manifesto and election plan? Is she piling in or is she off having nothing to do with it? No, she loves it. Well, appears to love it.
所以希思在所有这些联合政府的事情上稍微顺应了潮流。他周围的所有那些温和的保守党人，那些他身边的贵族式人物，威利·怀特劳（Willie Whitelaw）、伊恩·吉尔摩爵士（Sir Ian Gilmour）、彼得·沃克（Peter Walker）之类的人，这些名字对我们的一些老听众或了解未来20年左右英国政治的人来说会很熟悉。他们喜欢所有这些东西。聚在一起，为了国家利益，抛开部落主义，达成共识。事实上，报纸也喜欢它。
So Heath is slightly running with the tide with all this coalition business. All his sort of wet Tory moderates, the kind of patrician people that he surrounds himself with, the Willie Whitehaws and Sir Ian Gilmores and Peter Walkers and people like this, names that will be familiar to some of our older listeners or people who know about British politics in the next 20 years or so. They love all this stuff. Getting together and the national interest, putting aside tribalism, consensus. And indeed, the papers love it.
报纸对这一点都很客气，汤姆。《卫报》、《泰晤士报》，他们都说，让我们组建一个联合政府，也许是自由党-保守党，也许是自由党-工党，也许是保守党-工党，为了国家利益组建民族政府。我想是这样，多米尼克。我的意思是，你知道，你对此非常嘲讽，但我认为这在某种程度上是
The papers are all very be kind about this, Tom. The Guardian, the Times, they all say, let's have a coalition, maybe liberal Tory, maybe liberal Labour, maybe Tory Labour, national government in the national interest. I suppose so, Dominic. I mean, you know, you're being very sneery about this, but I suppose it's
明智的政治，因为在上次选举之后，如果索普（Thorpe）和希思能够走到一起，那么就会有一个联合政府。所以保守党是否在某种程度上为未来的联合政府伙伴铺路？是的，可以说。他们认为自由党会再次表现良好。但抱歉，我从未回答你关于撒切尔夫人的问题。撒切尔夫人从未对所有这些说过一句抱怨的话。现在，当然，后来她是妥协和共识的死敌。但我之前说过她不是一颗巨大的明星，因为她在他们的第一次竞选活动中并没有真正发挥太大作用。那么她在这次竞选中发挥了很大作用吗？
sensible politics on one level, because after the previous election, had Thorpe and Heath been able to get together, then there would have been a coalition. So is there a sense in which the Tories are kind of laying out their stall for future coalition partners? Yes, arguably. They think that the liberals will do well again. But sorry, I never answered you about Mrs. Thatcher. Mrs. Thatcher never says a word of complaints about all this. Now, of course, later on, she's the sworn foe of compromise and consensus. But actually, I said previously she hadn't been a massive star because she hadn't really featured that much in their first election campaign. So does she feature a
在这次竞选中，她出现的次数比任何其他保守党前座议员都多。所以她是突围明星。她是突围明星。所以有时有人说，当她几个月后成为保守党领袖时，没人听说过她，她是最大的黑马。那根本不是真的。她在党派政治广播中出现的次数甚至比希思本人还要多，因为他们认为希思太尖刻了。
lot in this one? In this one, she appears more often than any other Tory frontbencher. So she's the breakout star. She's the breakout star. So it's sometimes said that when she became Tory leader a few months later, no one had ever heard of her and she was the darkest of dark horses. That's not true at all. She features in their party political broadcasts more than even Heath himself does, because they think Heath is very abrasive.
撒切尔夫人也许更温和、更出名，但是的，撒切尔夫人会吸引那个关键的家庭主妇群体，而希思则不会。实际上，撒切尔夫人为每个人准备了一份礼物。她有一个非凡的贿赂。如果你是索尔兹伯里的房主，比如说在威尔特郡，无论通货膨胀和利率涨到多高——显然这是一个通货膨胀非常高的时期——撒切尔夫人会将你的抵押贷款利率上限设定在9.5%。它绝对不会高于那个水平。所以她在对抗市场。她在对抗市场。这是纯粹的疯狂的国家主义。法团主义。这是纯粹的疯狂的国家主义。
Mrs. Thatcher is maybe more emollient, famous, but yes, Mrs. Thatcher would appeal to that crucial dynamic of housewives, which Heath will not appeal to. And actually, Mrs. Thatcher has a treat for everybody. She has an extraordinary bribe. If you're a homeowner in Salisbury, let's say, in Wiltshire, no matter how high inflation and interest rates go, obviously this is a period of very high inflation, Mrs. Thatcher will cap your mortgage rate at 9.5%. There is no way it will go higher than that. So she's bucking the market. She is bucking the market. It's pure statism gone mad. Corporatism. It is pure statism gone mad.
法团主义。这是法团主义。实际上，那些后来成为她在右翼的伟大崇拜者的人对此感到非常震惊。他们说，这只是对中产阶级房主最糟糕的国家主义贿赂。但她是一个伟大的推销员。她上电视。她承诺，你知道，我们会保护你们，保护那些努力支付抵押贷款的中产阶级家庭，以及所有这些东西。
Corporatism. It is corporatism. And actually, people who would subsequently become her great admirers on the right are really appalled by this. They say, this is just the most terrible status bribe for mid-class homeowners. But she's a great salesman for it. She goes on TV. She's promising, you know, we'll protect you at the value of middle-class families, struggling to pay the mortgage and all this kind of stuff.
勤劳、体面的家庭。这基本上是保守党在1974年10月拥有的唯一政策。其余的都是关于联合政府的废话。他去卡迪夫参加了他的第一次大型公开会议。这是那个新的、可爱的、风趣的泰德·希思。他说话声音很小，没人能听清他在说什么，因为他显然被告知要降低调门。第一个问题来了，
Hardworking, decent families. And this is basically the only policy that the Tories have in October 1974. The rest is all just waffle about coalitions. He goes to his first big public meeting in Cardiff. This is the new cuddly, jovial Ted Heath. And he speaks very quietly and no one can hear what he's saying because he's obviously been told to tone it down. And the first question comes in,
有人说，希思先生，你对抗通货膨胀的第一步是什么？他说，看看情况到底如何。是的。他们说，好吧，那你打算做什么？他说，
somebody says, what will be your first move against inflation, Mr. Heath? And he says, to see precisely what the situation is. Yeah. And they say, well, then what will you do? And he says,
我会采取适当的行动。好吧，那太棒了。来吧。那真是大师级的。你得给我们更多东西。所以气氛非常严峻。右翼人士处于绝对的痛苦和绝望之中。菲利普·拉金（Philip Larkin），汤姆，你是诗人菲利普·拉金的粉丝吗？
I'll take the appropriate action. Well, that's brilliant. Come on. That's masterly. You've got to give us more than that. So the mood is very grim. People on the right are just in absolute misery and despair. Philip Larkin, Tom, are you a fan of Philip Larkin, the poet?
是的。我的意思是，他基本上是此时西欧最右翼的人。是的。他写信给金斯利·艾米斯（Kingsley Amis），他说，我们永远不会再有保守党政府了。只会有一系列的工党政府，然后俄国人会介入。艾米斯回信给他说，听着，这将是最后一次自由选举。我们永远不会再被允许投票了。但许多富裕的、上中产阶级的人，
Yeah. I mean, he's basically the most right-wing person in Western Europe at this point. Yeah. And he writes to Kingsley Amos and he says, we're never going to have another conservative government. There's just going to be a series of Labour governments and then the Russians are going to step in. Amos writes back to him and he says, listen, this is going to be the last free election. We'll never be allowed to vote again. But a lot of people who are affluent, upper middle class,
那些做得很好的人，对此感到绝对绝望。有产阶级中有一种真正的恐慌感，道德和政治上的恐慌，因为他们得到了撒切尔夫人的贿赂提议，但他们基本上知道保守党不会获胜。所以民调肯定对保守党不利？哦，非常不利。非常不利。所以工党在竞选开始时有大约8%到10%的领先优势，因为泰德·希思被视为——他就像一个赢不了比赛的足球教练，汤姆。现在，你可能想知道，我们的老朋友自由党发生了什么？
people who've done very well, are in absolute despair about all this. There's a real sense of panic, of moral and political panic among the propertied classes because they've got their bribe offer from Mrs Thatcher, but they basically know that the Tories aren't going to get in. So the polls are definitely against the Tories? Oh, very much so. Very much so. So Labour have a lead of about 8% to 10% going into the campaign because Ted Heath is disregarded as, he's like a football manager who just can't win a game, Tom. Now, you may be wondering, what's happened to our old friends, the Liberals?
我确实在想那个。所以自由党，那个由杰里米·索普（Jeremy Thorpe）领导的中间派政党，他后来将因埃克斯穆尔（Exmoor）的一条狗的死亡而负责，并被指控谋杀，但最终脱罪。但无论如何，那都是题外话。我们已经做过一集关于那个的节目了。
I am wondering about that. So the Liberals, the party in the centre, led by Jeremy Thorpe, who will go on to be responsible for the death of a dog on Exmoor and be accused of murder and get off. But anyway, that's all by the by. We've done an episode on that.
所以杰里米·索普在做什么？这涉及气垫船吗？重要的是要说，无论保守党有什么其他缺点。他们是这次选举中唯一一个没有以某种方式
So what is Jeremy Thorpe up to? And does it involve hovercrafts? It's important to say that whatever the tour is, other failings. They're the only party in this election who have not in some way
参与谋杀阴谋的政党。那是真的。是的，确实有那个。关于泰德，你想说什么就说什么，但他从未策划过谋杀。无论是狗、他的前情人，还是他自己的助手
been involved in a murder plot. That's true. Yeah, there is that. Say what you like about Teddy, but he never plotted it as a murder. Either a dog, his ex-lover, or one of his own aides
秘书，对，所以杰里米·索普，现在你会认为，因为他是1974年第一次选举的突围明星，这是他的时刻吗？他自己也这么认为，但他犯了一个可怕的错误，汤姆。他决定去巡回全国——我甚至不敢相信我要说出来，因为它听起来太荒谬了——他要在这次选举中乘坐气垫船巡回全国。我甚至不敢相信我要说出来，因为它听起来太荒谬了。他要在这次选举中乘坐气垫船巡回全国。这是因为所有自由党的目标选区都在海岸上吗？
secretary right so jeremy thorpe now you would think because he was the breakout star of the first 1974 election is this his moment and he thinks that himself but he has made a terrible mistake tom he decides to go to tour the land i can't even believe i'm going to say it because it sounds so ridiculous he's going to tour the land by hover can't even believe I'm going to say it because it sounds so ridiculous. He's going to tour the land by hovercraft in this election. Is this because all the Liberal target seats are on the coast?
有很多在海岸上，在南部，是的，在南海岸。我的意思是，西南部有很多。我的意思是，你怎么能乘坐气垫船到达西南部的中心地带？你会绕着边缘走吗，也许？托姆和德文郡？我的意思是，那是他们的想法。
There's a lot on the coast, on the south, yeah, on the south coast. I mean, there are quite a lot in the West Country. I mean, how do you get to the heart of the West Country on a hovercraft? Will you go round the edge, maybe? Tormund and Devon? I mean, that's the thinking.
但显然，我的意思是，英国，我不知道英国在70年代是否特别热衷于气垫船。当然，我记得在学校时——非常为它们感到自豪。在70年代末，所有的谈话都是关于气垫船的。是的。就像协和式飞机一样。在我看来，是的。
But obviously, I mean, Britain, I don't know whether Britain is peculiarly invested in hovercrafts in the 70s. Certainly, I remember being at school- Very proud of them. In the sort of late years of the 70s, all the talk was of hovercrafts. Yeah. It's like Concorde. In my mind, yeah.
协和式飞机、北海石油、气垫船。这就是英国经济的未来。是的。这就是英国未来的样子。所以杰里米·索普正在将自己与一个光明的技术未来联系起来，也许还有一丝科幻小说的味道。是的。这一切都很辉煌、令人兴奋，也许人们也会背着那些气垫东西到处走。完全正确。在木星度假。完全正确。那么结果如何呢？结果非常糟糕。所以汤姆，他的气垫船竞选的高潮发生在西德茅斯（Sidmouth）。
Concorde, North Sea oil, the hovercraft. This is the future of the British economy. Yeah. This is what Britain will look like. So Jeremy Thorpe is associating himself with a bright technological future, perhaps a hint of science fiction. Yes. It's all glorious and exciting and maybe people will go around with those hover things on their backs as well. Exactly. Holidays in Jupiter. Exactly. So how does that pan out? It goes very badly. So Tom, the climax of his hovercraft campaign takes place at Sidmouth.
一位随索普竞选团队旅行的记者心想，你知道，我是在写下一任首相吗？他写道：第一波浪潮袭来时，气垫船正从海滩转向，准备前往怀特岛。当自由党领袖差点被一些碎浪卷入海中时，我正拉着他身后的一根绳子。所以那里有摄影师捕捉到了这一幕，索普和另一个叫约翰·帕多（John Pardo）的自由党人带着他们的财物在海中蹒跚而行。所以这绝对是一个充满活力、积极进取的未来首相的形象。气垫船实际上最终被海浪完全摧毁了。
And a reporter who's traveling with Thorpe's campaign thinking, you know, could I be writing about the next prime minister? He writes as follows. The first wave struck just as the craft was turning off the beach to head away to the Isle of Wight. I was pulling on one rope just behind the liberal leader when he was nearly swept into the sea by some breakers. So there are photographers there who are capturing this scene as Thorpe and another liberal guy called John Pardo are staggering through the sea with their possessions. So absolutely the image of a dynamic, go-getting future prime minister. The hovercraft actually ends up being completely destroyed by the waves.
他们最终把它丢弃在海滩上，在鹅卵石上，汤姆。当然，每个人都拍了照片，说这就是“杰里米·索普的英国”。所以它被视为——我的意思是，它被视为英国和自由党的隐喻，是吗？是的。绝对是。除此之外，这是一场极其平淡的竞选。一直在下雨。我的意思是，那是十月，所以非常阴沉。
They'd end up abandoning it, Tom, on the beach, on the shingle. And of course, everyone then takes photos of this and says, Jeremy Thorpe's Britain. So it's seen as, I mean, it's seen as a metaphor for Britain and for the liberals, is it? It is. Absolutely, it is. Other than this, it's an incredibly uneventful campaign. It rains all the time. I mean, it's October, so it's very gloomy.
这是什么？威尔逊和希思第四次面对面。所以这有点像那些足总杯或世界杯决赛之类的东西，你已经看过同样的球队一千次了。总是零比零。德国对阵阿根廷。这太令人沮丧了。这就是人们的感觉。
This is the, what is this? The fourth time that Wilson and Heath have faced each other. So it's a bit like one of those FA Cup or World Cup finals or something, where you've seen the same teams a thousand times. It's always nil-nil. Germany against Argentina. It's just so depressing. This is how people feel.
威尔逊有相当舒适的领先优势。他只是在喋喋不休地谈论联合政府和民族团结，他没有任何政策。索普掉进了海里。是的，他乘坐气垫船掉进了海里。唯一可能阻碍威尔逊的东西，汤姆，是当时英国最受欢迎的报纸。不一定是销量最高的，
Wilson has a pretty comfortable lead. He's just wittering on about coalitions and national unity, and he hasn't got any policies. Thorpe's falling into the sea. Yeah, fell into the sea in his hovercraft. The only thing that can possibly stand in Wilson's way, Tom, is Britain's favourite newspaper at the time. Not necessarily the best-selling,
但可能是中产阶级最喜欢的，当然就是女王陛下的《每日邮报》（Daily Mail）。因为消息传到了威尔逊总部，说《每日邮报》准备了一个关于威尔逊财务状况的巨大故事。实际上，威尔逊的财务状况有点神秘。他从他写的一本关于他60年代政府的巨大且极其无聊的书里得到了所有这些版税。他似乎把这些版税中的很大一部分给了玛西娅，用于支付她孩子的学费。其余的都在一个瑞士银行账户里。对。所以花在学费上和瑞士银行账户里。我的意思是，托尼·本会怎么想？托尼·本根本不会留下深刻印象。《每日邮报》有一个关于这个的巨大故事，
but probably the one that Middle England enjoyed most, which is, of course, Her Majesty's Daily Mail. Because the news reaches Wilson headquarters, the Daily Mail had prepared this enormous story on Wilson's finances. And actually, Wilson's finances are a little bit mysterious. He'd got all these royalties from a massive and incredibly boring book that he'd written about his 1960s government. And he'd given a lot of these royalties, it seems, to Marcia to spend on school fees for her children. And the rest was in a Swiss bank account. Right. So spending on school fees and Swiss bank accounts. I mean, what would Tony Benn make of that? Tony Benn would not be impressed at all. And the Daily Mail have got this huge story about this,
他们计划刊登。威尔逊团队对此绝对是如坐针毡。然后有各种……他们等着《每日邮报》在某天晚上刊登。有各种传言传来。有炸弹恐慌。《每日邮报》总部所在地被疏散了。正在举行各种高层会议，讨论他们是否要刊登这个可能彻底改变选举进程的故事。实际上威尔逊的律师，我想是古德曼勋爵（Lord Goodman），
which they're planning to run. And the Wilson team are in absolute kind of tenterhooks about it. And then there's all kinds of... They're waiting for the mail to run at one night. And there's all rumours coming in. There's been a bomb scare. A mail had quarters to the place had been evacuated. There are all kind of high level meetings taking place about where they're going to run this story that could completely change the course of the election. And actually Wilson's lawyer, Lord Goodman, I think it is,
赢得了这一天，并说服他们不要刊登，或者恐吓他们不要刊登这个故事。所以第二天过去了，他们没有刊登关于威尔逊财务状况的故事。所以随着投票日10月10日的临近，威尔逊的财务状况实际上有一种必然性。所以随着投票日10月10日的临近，
wins the day and persuades them not to run it or intimidates them into not running the story. So the next day comes and goes and they don't run the story about Wilson's finances. So as polling day approaches, 10th of October, there's an inevitability actually about Wilson's finances. So as polling day approaches, 10th of October,
威尔逊的胜利实际上有一种必然性。顺便说一句，所有的报纸，很少有报纸希望他赢。《卫报》，《卫报》希望他赢。自由党。《卫报》喜欢气垫船生意。《泰晤士报》想要一个保守党-自由党联合政府。《每日邮报》想要一个保守党-自由党联合政府。
there's an inevitability actually about Wilson's victory. All the newspapers, by the way, very few of the newspapers want him to win. The Guardian, the Guardian wants to win. The Liberals. Guardian loves the hovercraft business. The Times wants a Tory-Liberal coalition. The Mail wants a Tory-Liberal coalition.
所以投票日到了，10月10日星期四，大雨倾盆。威尔逊的助手们显然把所有时间都花在互相争吵上。玛西娅有一堆镇静剂，她用白兰地送服，所以她也加入了喝酒的行列。哦，绝对是的。他们坐着，起初这很棒。BBC说他们将获得150个席位的多数。威尔逊和他的团队。但随着夜晚的推移，那个多数席位被一点一点地削减。他最终确实获得了多数席位，汤姆，但只有三个席位。所以那是什么，只比他在上次选举中多七八个席位？他开始时，是的。所以实际上，工党的选票自二月以来有所下降。保守党的选票下降得更多。
So the polling day comes, Thursday, the 10th of october pouring with rain wilson's aides just obviously spend all the time bickering among themselves marcia has got a load of sedatives which she's washing down with brandy so she's joined in the drinking oh absolutely yeah and they sit up and at first it's brilliant the bbc say they're going to get 150 seat majority wilson and co. But then as the night goes on, that majority gets whittled down and down and down. And he does end up with the majority, Tom, but of just three seats. So that's what, only seven or eight more than he'd had in the previous election? Then he started with, yeah. So actually, Labour's vote has fallen since February. The Tory vote had fallen even more.
这实际上是他们自1945年以来在选票数量上表现最差的一次。在选票份额上，保守党的表现很糟糕，36%，我认为这是他们当时有史以来最差的。但里希·苏纳克（Rishi Sunak）现在会为了这些数字付出什么呢？对。这是一个公平的观点。所以希思完了。休息后我们会谈到希思。在进入休息之前，你会很高兴听到威尔逊以一种荒谬的混乱和无组织的方式庆祝。如果他不这样做，我会感到失望。所以他们花了一晚上争论
It's actually their worst performance since 1945 in number of votes. And vote share, the Tory performance was terrible, 36%, which is, I think, their worst ever at that point. But what wouldn't Rishi Sunak give for those figures now? Right. That's a fair point. So Heath is done. We'll come on to Heath after the break. Just before we go into the break, you'll be pleased to hear that Wilson celebrates in a ludicrously disorganized and chaotic way. I'd be disappointed if he didn't. So they spend the evening arguing about
谁要去参加胜利派对。关于他最忠诚的助手之一，阿尔伯特·默里（Albert Murray），他基本上为他拎包，发生了一场争论。玛西娅说他不被允许进入。所以其他人抵制了他的胜利派对，因为阿尔伯特不被允许进入。有很大的愤怒。
who's going to go to the victory party. There's an argument about one of his most faithful aides, who's got Albert Murray, who basically carries his bag for him. Marcia says he's not allowed in. So the others have just taken a dislike to him. So the others boycott his victory party because Albert's not allowed in. There's a great deal of rage.
我想他们去了另一家酒店看电视。然后第二天，关于谁被允许乘坐飞机回伦敦又发生了一场大争论。他们终于到了伦敦，去了工党总部运输大厦（Transport House）进行胜利庆祝。那里有炸弹恐慌。所以，爱尔兰共和军的问题再次笼罩着整个事情。所以有炸弹恐慌，整个地方必须被疏散。然后是真正的大新闻。那天，他们回到了伦敦，他们现在有了微小的多数席位，他们可以着手扭转国家的命运。哈罗德·威尔逊的政策主管伯纳德·多诺霍在唐宁街10号，他实际上要出去过周末，清空一下头脑，思考他们需要做什么来解决问题。
They go off to a different hotel, I think, to watch the telly. Then the next day, there's a big argument about who's going to be allowed on the flight home to London. They finally get to London to go to Transport House, Labour Party headquarters for their victory celebration. There is a bomb scare. So again, that issue of the IRA hangs over the whole thing. So there's a bomb scare, the whole place has to be evacuated. And then the really, really big news. That day, they've got back to London, they now have the tiny majority and they can look into turning the nation's fortunes around. And Bernard Donoghue, the policy chief of Harold Wilson, is at number 10, and he's actually going to go off for the weekend and kind of clear his mind and think about what they need to do to sort things out.
就在他这样做之前，威尔逊的一位公务员走进来对他说，我有一些消息。午餐谈判取得了重大突破。重大突破是现在禁止每个人在唐宁街10号吃午餐来解决所有问题。多诺霍那天晚上在日记中写道，我希望哈罗德在充当玛西娅敌意的信使之余，能有一分钟时间思考国家的经济。国家正在破产。他正处于政治胜利的时刻，但他把时间花在了这些关于谁在唐宁街10号吃午餐的琐碎事情上，充当信使。太棒了。休息后，我们将看看选举的直接后果。谁上升了？谁下降了？
And just before he does, one of Wilson's civil servants comes in and says to him, I've got some news. There's been a big breakthrough in the lunch negotiations. And the big breakthrough is everybody is now banned from having lunch in number 10 to sort it all out. And Donoghue writes in his diary that evening, I hope Harold gets a minute to think about the country's economy in between acting as a messenger for Marcia's hostilities. The nation is going bust. He's at a moment of political triumph, and he spends his time as a messenger on these pathetically trivial matters of who eats lunch in number 10. Brilliant. After the break, we will look at the immediate aftermath of the election. Who's up? Who's down?
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《历史的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。谁上升了？谁下降了？以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》，这是我们关于英国1974年这一单一年份的四部分史诗系列的最后一部分。多米尼克，我们以爱尔兰共和军对一家酒吧的爆炸袭击开始了这一集，我们将以爱尔兰共和军对另一家酒吧的爆炸袭击开始这一半，这次是在伯明翰。是的，这在我的想象中非常生动，因为它出现在乔纳森·科（Jonathan Coe）关于70年代在伯明翰成长的精彩小说《腐烂者俱乐部》（The Rotter's Club）中。是的，确实如此。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. Who's up? Who's down? and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History for the final segment of our four-part epic on the single year of 1974 in Britain. And Dominic, we began this episode with a bombing by the ira of a pub and we're going to begin this half with the bombing of another pub by the ira and this was in birmingham yes it's very vivid in my imagination because it's um it features in jonathan co's brilliant novel about growing up in birmingham in 70s, The Rotter's Club. Yes, it does.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。谁在上升？谁在下降？想要提前购买现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史余谈》，这是我们关于1974年英国这一史诗般年份的四集系列节目的最后一部分。多米尼克，我们在这一集开头提到了爱尔兰共和军对一家酒吧的爆炸袭击，而这一半节目的开头我们将讲述爱尔兰共和军对另一家酒吧的爆炸袭击，这次是在伯明翰。是的，这在我的想象中非常生动，因为它出现在乔纳森·科关于在70年代伯明翰成长的精彩小说《腐败者俱乐部》中。是的，确实如此。
The hero's sister's boyfriend dies in it. That's right. Yes, it's a brilliant book and a very affecting moment. So this is six weeks after the Guildford bombing. So it's about five weeks after the general election. And it's a Thursday in Birmingham. It's payday in Birmingham. So the pubs are crowded. There's a basement pub called the Tavern in the Town, not far from New Street Station.
英雄妹妹的男朋友在里面死了。没错。是的，这是一本精彩的书，也是一个非常感人的时刻。这是吉尔福德爆炸案发生六周后。也就是大选结束约五周后。那是伯明翰的一个星期四。伯明翰的发薪日。所以酒吧里挤满了人。在离新街车站不远的地方，有一家名为“城镇酒馆”的地下室酒吧。
So if those people are familiar with the center of Birmingham. And just after about 8.15, the people in that pub, they hear a kind of muffled thump. And they don't know it, but a bomb has just gone off at the bottom of the Rotunda in Birmingham, the pub at the bottom of Rotunda, which is just a few minutes walk away. And exactly 10 minutes after that, so there's crowds gathering outside this pub now as people are moving down the street. A bomb goes off in the tavern in the town as well. So it's the second bombing of the night. And if you read the descriptions in the newspapers. The descriptions are horrific. So a fireman recalls seeing a torso with no arms or legs and a spongy mess where its head had been.
如果那些人熟悉伯明翰市中心的话。大约8点15分刚过，酒吧里的人听到了一声闷响。他们不知道，伯明翰圆形大厅底部刚刚发生了一起爆炸，圆形大厅底部的酒吧距离这里只有几分钟的步行路程。就在那之后整整10分钟，当人们沿着街道移动时，酒吧外已经聚集了人群。城镇酒馆也发生了爆炸。所以这是当晚的第二次爆炸。如果你读报纸上的描述。描述非常可怕。一位消防员回忆说，看到一具没有胳膊或腿的躯干，头部的位置是一团海绵状的烂肉。
The torso was not only wriggling, it was also through the spongy mess screaming. I mean, it's so horrible. Yeah, so the fireman asked the TV crews to film some of these scenes and the TV crews refused because they said they were too horrific. 21 people were killed, almost 200 injured, some of them very badly. There was actually a third bomb in a wine bar. So basically what had happened is the IRA had put a bomb in the first pub at the bottom of the rotunda. Then they had planned it so that as people fled, a second bomb in a pub
那具躯干不仅在蠕动，还在那团海绵状的烂肉中尖叫。我的意思是，这太可怕了。是的，所以消防员要求电视摄制组拍摄其中一些场景，但电视摄制组拒绝了，因为他们说这些场景太可怕了。21人死亡，近200人受伤，其中一些人伤势非常严重。实际上还有第三枚炸弹在一家酒吧里。所以基本上发生的事情是，爱尔兰共和军在圆形大厅底部的第一个酒吧里放了一枚炸弹。然后他们计划好，当人们逃跑时，第二枚炸弹会在一个酒吧里
just down the street would catch them. They claimed they had telephoned warnings, but they did so with so little time before the pub bombs went off. There was no way that the police could act or the pubs could be evacuated. And because it comes so soon after the Guildford bombing, I think there's a real sense of shock, of trauma, particularly in the city of Birmingham, in the aftermath of all this. There was talk at the time, briefly, that this would spark, you know, sort of sectarian or sort of backlash politics in britain itself so what anti-irish
就在街下，会炸到他们。他们声称他们打过警告电话，但他们在酒吧炸弹爆炸前的时间太短了。警方根本无法采取行动，酒吧也无法疏散。而且因为它发生在吉尔福德爆炸案之后不久，我认为有一种真正的震惊感、创伤感，特别是在伯明翰市，在这一切的余波中。当时曾短暂地传言，这会在英国本土引发某种宗派主义或某种反弹政治，所以反爱尔兰
pogroms anti-irish exactly so there's there were a few isolated incidents so there's petrol bombs that are thrown as an irish pub in west london there are talks about people attacking irish community centers and things but actually by and large it doesn't really come to very much the government in the aftermath passed a prevention of Terrorism Act. So that allowed people to be held for questioning for seven days, for example. But actually, looking at it now, I think the striking thing is actually how muted... Except that, as with Guildford, the police are looking to finger people they can blame. And there's again, there's another terrible miscarriage of justice, isn't there? Yeah, the Birmingham Six. So that's six men. They're Irishmen who'd lived in Birmingham since the 60s. They're arrested. Confessions are beaten out of them. They were in prison until 1991,
大屠杀，反爱尔兰，没错，所以有一些孤立的事件，比如在西伦敦的一家爱尔兰酒吧被投掷汽油弹，有人谈论攻击爱尔兰社区中心之类的事情，但实际上总的来说，并没有造成太大的影响。政府在事后通过了《防止恐怖主义法》。例如，这允许人们被拘留审问七天。但实际上，现在回顾起来，我认为引人注目的是实际上是多么的沉默……除了像吉尔福德案一样，警方正在寻找可以指责的人。而且又发生了一起可怕的司法不公，不是吗？是的，伯明翰六人组。那是六个人。他们是自60年代以来一直住在伯明翰的爱尔兰人。他们被捕了。供词是被严刑拷打出来的。他们一直被关在监狱里直到1991年，
until the conviction was overturned. So this is a grim background to the start of Wilson's, what is it now? I'm losing track. His fourth term, his third term? It depends how you measure it, Tom, but it's a sort of continuation. He's won four elections. He's won four elections out of five. So whatever you say about Harold Wilson, he's a very cunning operator. He's very good at elections. Even 1970, which he lost, he actually did well to come as, I would argue, given his record in government, I think he actually did well to come within a, you know, to have a chance of winning it.
直到定罪被推翻。所以这是威尔逊开始他现在的任期的一个严峻背景，是什么来着？我记不清了。他的第四个任期，他的第三个任期？这取决于你如何衡量它，汤姆，但这是一种延续。他赢得了四次选举。他在五次选举中赢了四次。所以无论你怎么评价哈罗德·威尔逊，他都是一个非常狡猾的操作者。他非常擅长选举。即使是1970年他输掉的那次，我认为他实际上做得很好，考虑到他在政府的记录，我认为他实际上做得很好，能够接近，你知道，有机会赢得它。
So Wilson appeals to people who want a quiet life. I think the key to Wilson is that people in Britain, I think in the 60s and 70s, they were tired. They were very anxious about change. They were conscious of no longer being top nation. And I think in some part of their minds, a lot of people didn't know that they were facing a very difficult transformation as the industries on which they'd relied, coal, shipbuilding, steel, all those kinds of things that they were clearly struggling, but they didn't really want to face it. Actually, the person we've mentioned a lot who writes this diary, Bernard Donoghue, Wilson's policy chief, is brilliant on all this in his diaries and in his memoirs, saying, we knew that change would have to come,
所以威尔逊吸引了那些想要平静生活的人。我认为威尔逊的关键在于英国人，我认为在60年代和70年代，他们累了。他们对变化感到非常焦虑。他们意识到自己不再是顶级国家了。而且我认为在他们思想的某个部分，很多人并不知道他们正面临着非常困难的转型，因为他们所依赖的行业，煤炭、造船、钢铁，所有这些他们显然在挣扎的事情，但他们并不真的想面对它。实际上，我们提到的经常写这本日记的人，伯纳德·多诺霍，威尔逊的政策主管，在他的日记和回忆录中对这一切的描述非常精彩，他说，我们知道变化迟早会到来，
but actually we were benefiting electorally from people who wanted to put that off. And Wilson's political persona, I think, is one of very, very small-c conservatism by this point. It's basically, let's not frighten the horses, no conflicts with the unions, nothing that will lead to any kind of public controversy, just steady as she goes. And actually, the orderly management of decline to some extent, Tom. So I suppose there are two radical solutions to this crisis, both of which involve a pretty dramatic restructuring of the economy. The first would be the one proposed by Tony Benn, that you become almost a siege economy. The Uthamial nose at the power of international capital. And the other is the radical turn that the British economy does end up taking, most famously with Mrs. Thatcher, but also, of course, as you brilliantly point out in your book, before that with Dennis Healey. And is there a sense in the wake of the election that these are really the two alternatives, that just going with the status quo is going to be
但实际上我们从那些想推迟变化的人那里获得了选举利益。我认为威尔逊的政治形象在这一点上是非常非常小写的保守主义。基本上就是，不要惊吓到马匹，不要与工会发生冲突，不要做任何会导致任何公众争议的事情，只要稳步前进就行。实际上，在某种程度上是秩序井然地管理衰退，汤姆。所以我认为这场危机有两种激进的解决方案，两者都涉及对经济进行相当剧烈的重组。第一个是托尼·本提出的，即你几乎变成了一个围城经济。对国际资本的力量嗤之以鼻。另一个是英国经济最终采取的激进转向，最著名的是撒切尔夫人，当然，正如你在书中精彩指出的那样，在那之前还有丹尼斯·希利。在选举之后，是否有一种感觉，这确实是两种选择，仅仅维持现状将会是
inadequate? No, not initially, actually, Tom. So on the Tony Benn thing, whatever else you say about Tony Benn, he had a very coherent and thought through approach to dealing with the problem that Britain was facing, which was, as you say, a siege economy, protectionism, rebuild British industry behind a kind of tariff wall. Because the contrast with Wilson, in a way, it seems that all this stuff about dinners and whatever with Marcia, it's a displacement exercise. He doesn't want to have to engage with it. Agreed. Whereas Ben really is engaging with it.
不够的？不，最初不是，汤姆。所以关于托尼·本的事情，无论你怎么评价托尼·本，他对于处理英国面临的问题有一个非常连贯和深思熟虑的方法，那就是，正如你所说，围城经济、保护主义，在某种关税壁垒后重建英国工业。因为与威尔逊的对比，在某种程度上，似乎所有关于与玛莎共进晚餐之类的事情，都是一种转移注意力的做法。他不想参与其中。同意。而本确实在参与其中。
Yeah, absolutely. I totally agree, Tom. I mean, in fact, the people who are working on policy, the backroom boys, as it were, they are all boys except for Marcia, in number 10, say again and again in this period, 1974, 1975, 1976, he doesn't read the papers. He doesn't engage. Inflation is heading towards 30%, but he doesn't really want to do anything about it. And they're really frustrated by it, actually. And so what happens in the months immediately after the election? Is there any sense of an election bounce? No, not really. It's actually a sort of... Whatever they're... Letting the air out of the balloon? Yeah, the air out of a balloon. No,
是的，绝对同意，汤姆。我的意思是，事实上，那些在制定政策的人，也就是所谓的幕后人员，除了玛莎之外，在唐宁街10号，他们在这个时期，1974年、1975年、1976年，一次又一次地说，他不看报纸。他不参与。通货膨胀率正朝着30%迈进，但他并不真的想对此做任何事情。他们对此感到非常沮丧。那么选举后的几个月里发生了什么？有任何选举后的反弹感吗？不，真的没有。这实际上是一种……让气球泄气？是的，气球里的空气。不，
not at all. So actually, by the end of October, Dennis Healy, who had thrown a lot of money around to try and win the election, meets his colleagues and actually says to them, do you know what, actually, all our projections were too optimistic. Surprise, surprise. We're going to be borrowing probably twice as much money as we thought we would. And that's going to rise three times as much in a year or so. Inflation is totally out of control now. It's well into 20%. The threshold payments, which we mentioned in the very first episode of this series, they've now been triggered, Tom, giving you an automatic pay rise because of inflation. They've been triggered 11 times. So adding to the kind of inflationary spiral. And in November, all the Wilson government get together, well, the Wilson cabinet, they get together at Chequers. So this is the official residence, country residence of the prime minister comes from very much a friend of the rest of history, Tom. James Callaghan, your great hero, later prime minister.
一点也不。所以实际上，到10月底，为了赢得选举而投入了大量资金的丹尼斯·希利会见了同事，实际上对他们说，你知道吗，实际上，我们所有的预测都太乐观了。惊喜，惊喜。我们借的钱可能比我们想象的要多两倍。而且在一年左右的时间里，这个数字还会增加三倍。通货膨胀现在完全失控了。它已经远远超过了20%。我们在本系列第一集中提到的门槛支付，汤姆，现在已经被触发了，因为通货膨胀而自动加薪。它们已经被触发了11次。所以增加了通货膨胀螺旋。11月，威尔逊政府的所有人聚在一起，好吧，威尔逊内阁，他们在契克斯聚在一起。所以这是首相的官邸，乡村官邸，非常来自历史的其余部分的朋友，汤姆。詹姆斯·卡拉汉，你的大英雄，后来的首相。
They say, what do you think, Jim? And Jim says, well, when I'm shaving in the morning, I say to myself that if I were a young man, I'd emigrate. And obviously, everybody laughs. But he's only half joking because he says to them in that meeting, if we carry on as we are, we will be stripped of our seat on the UN Security Council. Then he goes on to say, nothing in these papers makes me believe anything to the contrary, but I haven't got any solution, which obviously is slightly sub-ideal. Actually, the thing about emigrating, loads of people are emigrating.
他们说，你觉得怎么样，吉姆？吉姆说，嗯，我早上刮胡子的时候，对自己说，如果我是一个年轻人，我会移民。显然，大家都笑了。但他只是半开玩笑，因为他在那次会议上对他们说，如果我们继续这样下去，我们将被剥夺在联合国安理会的席位。然后他继续说，这些文件中的任何内容都不能让我相信有任何相反的情况，但我没有任何解决方案，这显然有点不太理想。实际上，关于移民的事情，很多人都在移民。
So David Bowie's off, isn't he, to New York? The Stones are still in the south of France, I think. Roger Moore, Tom? James Bond's left. Where does he go? So Roger Moore, I think, went in about 73. But actually, the Bond films themselves go, because Moonraker ends up being filmed in France at the end of the 70s for tax reasons. God, the humiliation. But also, lots of young people go. So many, in fact, that for the first time in 1974, New Zealand bring in controls to stop so many British people moving to New Zealand,
所以大卫·鲍伊要走了，不是吗，去纽约？我想滚石乐队还在法国南部。罗杰·摩尔，汤姆？詹姆斯·邦德离开了。他去哪了？所以罗杰·摩尔，我想大约在73年去了。但实际上，邦德电影本身也走了，因为《太空城》最终在70年代末因为税收原因在法国拍摄。天哪，真是羞辱。而且，很多年轻人也走了。事实上，人数之多，以至于1974年新西兰第一次引入管制，以阻止这么多英国人移居新西兰，
and Australia follows suit in 1975. So this is unprecedented, that they are closing their doors. I'll tell you some English tourists who are in Australia in the latter half after the election. It's the England cricket team. I knew this was coming. Playing against Rodney Marsh, the Australian wicketkeeper, not the Manchester City striker. A poorly behaved Manchester City striker from the last episode. And they get absolutely torn to pieces by Dennis Lilley and Geoff Thompson,
澳大利亚在1975年也效仿了。所以这是史无前例的，他们正在关上大门。我告诉你一些在选举后下半年在澳大利亚的英国游客。那是英格兰板球队。我知道这要来了。与澳大利亚守门员罗德尼·马什比赛，不是曼城前锋。上一集中那个表现不佳的曼城前锋。他们被丹尼斯·利利和杰夫·汤普森彻底撕碎了，
the most ferocious fast bowlers. And at one point, the abdominal protector, which David Lloyd, England batsman, he almost becomes a eunuch. Oh no. Cracked in two. And there, I'm afraid, is a metaphor, isn't it? There is a metaphor, yeah. So 1975, would you believe, so the year after the election, was the first year since records began that Britain's population fell because so many people were emigrating.
最凶猛的快球手。有一次，英格兰击球手大卫·劳埃德的腹部护具，他差点成了太监。哦不。裂成两半。恐怕这就是一个隐喻，不是吗？这是一个隐喻，是的。所以1975年，你敢相信吗，选举后的那一年，是有记录以来英国人口首次下降，因为太多人移民了。
So there is a solution to the immigration crisis. Or punch our economy into the abyss. Yeah, the Conservatives could totally crash the economy. Well, let us end with the Conservatives. So just on Wilson, just before Christmas, one of Wilson's aides gave him a paper saying, we are facing an economic Armageddon. As it turned out, the real reckoning was delayed until just after he left office in 1976. So he leaves office in the spring of 1976, absolutely knackered, worn out, massive bags under his eyes, very hanged dog. And almost immediately afterwards, there is a huge run on the pound and Britain has to seek a humiliating world record bailout from the International Monetary Fund, which later
所以移民危机有一个解决方案。或者把我们的经济打入深渊。是的，保守党可能会彻底搞垮经济。好吧，让我们以保守党结束。关于威尔逊，就在圣诞节前，威尔逊的一名助手给了他一份文件，说我们正面临经济世界末日。事实证明，真正的清算被推迟到他1976年离任后。所以他在1976年春天离任，绝对精疲力竭，筋疲力尽，眼袋巨大，非常垂头丧气。几乎就在那之后，英镑出现了巨大的挤兑，英国不得不向国际货币基金组织寻求羞辱性的世界纪录救助，这后来
becomes, of course, an item on the Thatterite charge sheet against the 1970s. That and the winter discontent, which follows later in the decade when there's kind of non-stop which later becomes, of course, an item on the Thatterite charge sheet against the 1970s. That and the winter discontent. Which follows later in the decade. When there's kind of non-stop strikes and gravediggers go on strike and things. So just before we do come to what happens to Edward Heath, just the state of the economy, because people say now that the country is in a worse mess than it's ever been in. It's not as bad, at least it doesn't seem as bad as it was back then. Is it actually the case the economy isn't quite as bad as we've been making it out to sound? I don't think it's as
当然，成为了撒切尔主义者针对70年代的指控清单中的一项。那和后来十年中发生的不满之冬。当有那种不停的……这后来当然成为了撒切尔主义者针对70年代的指控清单中的一项。那和不满之冬。这发生在十年后的晚些时候。当有那种不停的罢工，掘墓人罢工之类的事情时。所以就在我们谈到爱德华·希思发生了什么之前，只是经济状况，因为人们现在说这个国家处于比以往任何时候都更糟糕的混乱中。它没有那么糟糕，至少看起来没有当时那么糟糕。经济真的不像我们描述的那样糟糕吗？我不认为它像
bad as now as it was in the 70s by any means. No. I think the economy is obviously far from perfect now, but we don't have inflation at 27%. Economies fluctuate, Tom. So good times, bad times, stock markets rise and fall. To some degree, standing back, you might say a little bit of this is surface froth, right? But what's gone on with Britain between the 1950s and the 1980s is much more than surface froth. It's a massive structural change. So it's a process of kind of de-industrialization, isn't it? Yes, it absolutely is de-industrialization. So first into industry.
现在像70年代那样糟糕，绝不是。不。我认为经济现在显然远非完美，但我们没有27%的通货膨胀。经济是波动的，汤姆。所以好时光，坏时光，股市涨跌。在某种程度上，退后一步，你可能会说其中一点是表面泡沫，对吧？但英国在50年代到80年代之间发生的事情远不止是表面泡沫。这是一个巨大的结构性变化。所以这是一个去工业化的过程，不是吗？是的，绝对是去工业化。所以先进入工业。
And first out. And what's happening, I think, in the 70s is that the Wilson government and Callaghan government, like the Heath government before it, are trying to insulate, for completely humane and understandable reasons, trying to insulate a lot of working people from the consequences of that transformation. So when you read the papers and things, they will discuss a car factory in Scotland or something, and they will say, well, we just have to put money into it. We have to keep it going because if we let it fold, thousands of people will lose their jobs. The effect on the local community will be terrible. We don't want to be a government that allows that to happen. We'll find the money. And the danger with doing that, of course, is you just put off the evil day and you make it worse and worse. And I think there was a definite sense
然后先出来。我认为70年代发生的事情是，威尔逊政府和卡拉汉政府，就像之前的希思政府一样，正试图保护，出于完全人道和可以理解的原因，试图保护许多劳动人民免受这种转型的后果。所以当你读报纸之类的时候，他们会讨论苏格兰的一家汽车工厂什么的，他们会说，嗯，我们必须投入资金。我们必须让它继续下去，因为如果我们让它倒闭，成千上万的人将失去工作。对当地社区的影响将是可怕的。我们不想成为一个允许这种情况发生的政府。我们会找到钱的。当然，这样做的危险在于你只是推迟了那一天，而且让情况变得越来越糟。我认为有一个明确的感觉
by the end of the 70s, and this is very palpable in the memoirs and the diaries of people in the Labour government, not the Tories, but the Labour government. There was a sense, we actually can't keep doing this forever. Something is going to have to change at some point. So in that sense, I think the economy, the picture was worse in the 70s because people knew that what would follow would be so brutal. Brutal. Exactly. Which I don't think we have now. Well, unless they are siding with the Benite diagnosis and the Benite prescription. But even the Benite prescription, you see, the Benite prescription is a really interesting one because when it was modelled, when people said, well, what would actually happen if we said sodu to the IMF and the World Bank and whatnot, and we sealed ourselves off from the world economy to
到70年代末，这在工党政府，不是保守党，而是工党政府的人的回忆录和日记中非常明显。有一种感觉，我们实际上不能永远这样下去。在某个时候，事情必须改变。所以从这个意义上说，我认为经济，70年代的情况更糟，因为人们知道接下来会发生的事情将是如此残酷。残酷。没错。我认为我们现在没有这种情况。好吧，除非他们站在本派的诊断和本派的处方一边。但即使是本派的处方，你看，本派的处方是一个非常有趣的处方，因为当它被建模时，当人们说，好吧，如果我们对国际货币基金组织和世界银行之类的人说去死，并且我们将自己与世界经济隔绝，那实际上会发生什么？
some extent? Actually, what would happen would be probably very, very high inflation. And even though lots of people would still be in work, there would probably be a massive drop in a lot of people's living standards because imports would be so expensive because everybody else would put up trade barriers against Britain. So the Benite solution was by no means a panacea. I mean, obviously, I don't think it was a panacea because I don't think it would have worked. But I mean, the idea that you could just go on as you were, just finding bailouts all the time, I don't think anybody thought that in the long run that would possibly be a solution. Okay. Well, let's just finish this by
在某种程度上？实际上，会发生的事情可能是非常非常高的通货膨胀。即使很多人仍然有工作，很多人的生活水平也可能会大幅下降，因为进口会变得非常昂贵，因为其他人会对英国设置贸易壁垒。所以本派的解决方案绝不是万灵药。我的意思是，显然，我不认为它是万灵药，因为我不认为它会奏效。但我的意思是，认为你可以像以前那样继续下去，一直寻找救助，我不认为有人认为从长远来看这可能是一个解决方案。好吧。好吧，让我们以
looking at what happens with the Tories. Because of course, the political figure who emerges from this, she's been a bit part player really so far, but she will become the dominant figure in the 80s, is Mrs. Thatcher, who ends up replacing Edward Heath as leader. Yeah. Although she shouldn't have done, Tom. That's the extraordinary thing. So first of all, Heath has now lost. He's lost three out of four elections.
看看保守党发生了什么来结束。因为当然，从这里走出来的政治人物，她到目前为止只是一个小角色，但她将成为80年代的主导人物，是撒切尔夫人，她最终取代了爱德华·希思成为领导人。是的。虽然她本不应该这样做，汤姆。这是非同寻常的事情。所以首先，希思现在输了。他在四次选举中输了三次。
And he's lost two in a row in a single year. So he really, I mean, he has to go. I don't think it's at all unreasonable to think that he would want to go. But he refuses to go. Very Ted Heath behaviour. He's sulky. He's sort of sullen. He doesn't want to talk to go. Very Ted Heath behaviour. He's sulky. He's sort of sullen. He doesn't want to talk to anybody,
而且他在一年内连续输了两次。所以他真的，我的意思是，他必须走。我不认为认为他想走是不合理的。但他拒绝走。非常泰德·希思的行为。他闷闷不乐。他有点阴沉。他不想和任何人说话，
but it strikes him as outrageous that people would suggest that he... I mean, he basically doesn't even want to admit that he's lost. Now, the most likely challenger is a man called Sir Keith Joseph, who had been Heath's Secretary of State for Health and Social Security. He was an heir to a construction firm fortune. Doesn't he come out in favor of eugenics or something? Well, we're going to come to this. He's a kind of Tory Robespierre, Tom. So he's pale, he's very priggish, he's incredibly serious, he's incredibly conscientious. He's one of the rare Tories, I think it's fair to say, who probably spends about 20 hours a day thinking about the plight of the poor, and he will physically writhe with agony. Isn't he a mad monk? People call him the mad monk.
但人们建议他……这让他感到愤怒。我的意思是，他基本上甚至不想承认他输了。现在，最可能的挑战者是一个叫基思·约瑟夫爵士的人，他曾是希思的卫生和社会保障大臣。他是建筑公司财富的继承人。他不是支持优生学什么的吗？好吧，我们要谈到这一点。他是一个保守党的罗伯斯庇尔，汤姆。所以他脸色苍白，非常拘谨，非常严肃，非常认真。我认为公平地说，他是罕见的保守党人之一，他可能每天花20个小时思考穷人的困境，他会因为痛苦而身体扭曲。他不是一个疯和尚吗？人们叫他疯和尚。
They call him the mad monk. And he undergoes this extraordinary conversion experience in the course of 1974. So all this is going on, from the kind of corporatist Toryism of the Heath era to free market radicalism. He says, I believed all this time I was a conservative. I see now I wasn't. But just to be clear, I mean, we today associate conservatism with free market economics. Yes. Principally because of Mrs. Thatcher and I guess Reagan as well. Yeah. But actually, letting the free market rip through institutions and people's livelihood and destroy industries and ways of living that have lasted for decades and often centuries, I mean, that's not conservative, really, is it? Ted Heath there on the podcast, lovely to welcome him.
他们叫他疯和尚。他在1974年期间经历了这种非凡的转变体验。所以这一切都在发生，从希思时代的某种社团主义保守主义到自由市场激进主义。他说，我一直相信我是一个保守党人。我现在看到我不是。但要明确一点，我的意思是，我们今天将保守主义与自由市场经济学联系起来。是的。主要是因为撒切尔夫人，我想还有里根。是的。但实际上，让自由市场在机构和人们的生计中横冲直撞，摧毁已经持续了几十年甚至几个世纪的行业和生活方式，我的意思是，那不是保守主义，真的，是吗？泰德·希思在播客上，很高兴欢迎他。
No, but all the choices facing people in this period whether on the far left the right whatever are all pretty bad awful they are so theo has written in the chat hence the term neo-conservative but actually theo the real term is neoliberal so a lot of real tom holland style well the people that tom was ventriloquizing, so sort of patrician consensual Tories who fought in tank battles in 1944. Thick glasses. Now with thick glasses. Yeah, great hair. They would say, this isn't really conservatism if it's free markets.
不，但这个时期人们面临的所有选择，无论是在极左、右翼还是其他方面，都很糟糕，很可怕。他们是，所以西奥在聊天中写道，因此有了新保守主义这个词，但实际上西奥，真正的术语是新自由主义。所以很多真正的汤姆·霍兰风格，好吧，汤姆在模仿的人，也就是1944年在坦克战中战斗的贵族共识保守党人。厚眼镜。现在戴着厚眼镜。是的，很棒的头发。他们会说，如果这是自由市场，这就不是真正的保守主义。
This is liberalism. This is Victorian liberalism, and we don't want any part of it in our party. And they would later say this of Mrs. Thatcher. Now, Keith Joseph doesn't think this. He's been converted to this kind of neoliberalism. And he says, we've done it all wrong. Everything that Ted Heath stood for is nonsense. All his friends are saying, come on, challenge Heath. Put us on a free market line. The tough medicine that is needed. And do you know what? He's going to do it. And Mrs. Thatcher will be his campaign manager. And then, like Enoch Powell before him, Joseph makes the terrible
这是自由主义。这是维多利亚时代的自由主义，我们不想在我们的党内有任何部分。他们后来会这样评价撒切尔夫人。现在，基思·约瑟夫不这么认为。他已经转变为这种新自由主义。他说，我们完全做错了。泰德·希思所代表的一切都是胡说八道。他所有的朋友都在说，来吧，挑战希思。让我们走自由市场路线。所需的强硬药物。你知道吗？他要这么做。撒切尔夫人将成为他的竞选经理。然后，像之前的伊诺克·鲍威尔一样，约瑟夫犯了一个可怕的
mistake of going to Birmingham to give a speech. And he goes to the Grand Hotel in Birmingham, and he gives this disastrous speech where he says, and I quote, the balance of our population, our human stock is threatened. And he says it's threatened because a high and rising proportion of children are being born to mothers least fitted to bring children into the world. And he says, we should make a massive effort to get working class women to use more birth control to stop them having children. He says, because if we don't, it'll mean the degeneration of Britain.
去伯明翰发表演讲的错误。他去了伯明翰的大酒店，发表了那次灾难性的演讲，他说，我引用，我们人口的平衡，我们的人类储备受到威胁。他说它受到威胁是因为出生在最不适合把孩子带到这个世界上的母亲身上的孩子比例很高且在上升。他说，我们应该做出巨大的努力，让工人阶级妇女使用更多的节育措施，以阻止她们生孩子。他说，因为如果我们不这样做，这意味着英国的退化。
The degeneration of the racial stock. Yeah. Is he kind of verging on saying that? Well, he doesn't use the words racial stock. I think it's fair to say, Tom. And I think he would be appalled. I mean, he's Jewish himself. Yes, by the way.
种族储备的退化。是的。他是在边缘说这些吗？好吧，他没有使用种族储备这个词。我认为公平地说，汤姆。我想他会感到震惊。我的意思是，他自己就是犹太人。是的，顺便说一句。
Harold Macmillan rather cruelly said he was the only boring jew i've ever known yes so i think a lot of people are absolutely appalled by this they think it's the most terrible gaffe private eye which we mentioned a few times the satirical magazine because of his enthusiasm for birth control took to calling him sashith instead of sakith and i think people just thought he's gone mad you know and he basically thinks oh I've made a terrible mistake and he effectively bows out he goes around the house of commons in November so it's only six weeks or so after the election saying to people oh I can't I'm not going to do
哈罗德·麦克米伦相当刻薄地说他是他见过的唯一一个无聊的犹太人，是的，所以我认为很多人对此感到非常震惊。他们认为这是最可怕的失礼。我们提到过几次的讽刺杂志《私家侦探》，因为他对比特币的热情，开始叫他萨希思而不是萨基思，我想人们只是认为他疯了，你知道，他基本上认为哦，我犯了一个可怕的错误，他有效地退出了，他在11月绕过下议院，所以离选举只有六周左右，对人们说哦，我不能，我不打算做
it because also he's not really cut out to be a leader anyway he's a kind of prince hamlet figure isn't he he is an absolute he's dithery. He delays. Yes. He's intellectual. People would often say of him, he's the only person they would meet who in meetings would genuinely strike his own head very hard when he was changing his mind. He'd like pummel his head and stuff, which they found disconcerting. So anyway, on the 21st of November, he goes into the office of his campaign manager and
它，因为他也不是真的适合当领导人，他是一个哈姆雷特王子式的人物，不是吗？他绝对是一个，他优柔寡断。他拖延。是的。他是知识分子。人们经常这样评价他，他是他们见过的唯一一个在会议中真正会因为改变主意而用力敲打自己头部的人。他会捶打自己的头之类的，他们觉得这令人不安。所以无论如何，在11月21日，他走进他竞选经理的办公室，
he says, Margaret, I'm not going to do it. And it's at that point, there's no doubt that it hadn't occurred to her before then, because she wanted to be Chancellor, not Prime Minister. It's at that point that she said to him, well, Keith, if you're not going to stand, I will. And then she goes home and she says to Dennis, her husband, I'm actually going to stand myself for the Tory leadership against Ted Heath. And Dennis said, you must be out of your mind. You haven't got a hope. You haven't got a hope. And so four days later, she ignores Dennis, obviously. Four days later, she goes to see Ted Heath in his office and she says to him, Ted, I'm going to
他说，玛格丽特，我不打算这么做。就在那一刻，毫无疑问，在那之前她没有想到这一点，因为她想成为财政大臣，而不是首相。就在那一刻，她对他说，好吧，基思，如果你不打算参选，我会的。然后她回家对她的丈夫丹尼斯说，我实际上要亲自参加保守党领导权竞选，对抗泰德·希思。丹尼斯说，你一定是疯了。你没有希望。你没有希望。所以四天后，她无视丹尼斯，显然。四天后，她去他的办公室见泰德·希思，她对他说，泰德，我要
stand against you for the leadership or whatever. And Ted Heath, all he says is, you'll lose. And Tom, the rest is history. Brilliant. So, so much more to come. The 70s, the Labour government. Yeah. We should get into that next year, because next year will be the anniversary, Tom, of her becoming Tory leader. Very exciting. So the perfect opportunity to do a series on the late 70s. So James Callaghan. I mean, the public, I think, I mean, they're desperate to hear a series of podcasts about James Callaghan. People have been repeatedly demanding, I think, I mean, they're desperate to hear a series of podcasts about James Callaghan.
参加领导权竞选对抗你，或者其他什么。泰德·希思，他只说，你会输的。汤姆，剩下的就是历史了。精彩。所以，还有更多要来的。70年代，工党政府。是的。我们明年应该深入探讨这个问题，因为明年将是她成为保守党领导人的周年纪念日，汤姆。非常令人兴奋。所以是做一个关于70年代末系列节目的绝佳机会。所以詹姆斯·卡拉汉。我的意思是，公众，我想，我的意思是，他们非常渴望听到一系列关于詹姆斯·卡拉汉的播客。人们一直在反复要求，我想，我的意思是，他们非常渴望听到一系列关于詹姆斯·卡拉汉的播客。
People have been repeatedly demanding it. And so it will come. So Dominic, thanks so much. We hope that you have all enjoyed that. I mean, I have to say, it kind of cheers me up. I feel depressed about the state of the country. That's good. And I kind of think, well, it's not as bad as it could have been.
人们一直在反复要求它。所以它会来的。所以多米尼克，非常感谢。我们希望你们都喜欢那个。我的意思是，我不得不说，它让我振作起来。我对国家的状态感到沮丧。那很好。而且我有点认为，好吧，它没有那么糟糕。
Tom, it's nice to end a podcast with you feeling more cheerful. Yeah. So on that cheery note, thank you very much for listening. And bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
汤姆，以你感觉更愉快的方式结束播客真是太好了。是的。所以带着那个愉快的音符，非常感谢你们的收听。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《其余的是娱乐》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。